Are we live.
Thank you.
Sweet.
Jesus.
Are we live?
Brian,
this is real powerful,
Greg.
Proops.
Thanks for doing this man.
Really appreciate it.
It's a pleasure,
Jo.
Pleasure.
See you,
sir.
Before we do this,
uh,
our podcast is sponsored by [inaudible] dot com go to o n.
N.
I.
T.
This is a short podcast.
I'll keep this brief as fuck.
Go get yourself some Alpha brain.
Some good gigs.
Help some brain vitamins and some shroom tech for your endurance,
which might socks,
right?
No,
it's fucking depressing.
I'm bringing a care package of,
uh,
on it to Mike Maxwell and San Diego tonight.
Nice.
We're always worried.
I don't know if he's,
he's struggling.
He drew a picture of me.
It's first to look at the shirt.
Yeah.
Mike Maxwell shirt.
This is the new,
a higher prime rate design that Mike's Mike,
Mike Maxwell did.
I'm a fucking wicked.
I'm addicted to his,
his artwork.
He's a very good artist and he's a very cool guy too.
Um,
uh,
he's uh,
gone with us on the road.
That's you.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah,
he's really good.
And again,
like I said,
a great guy too.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Uh,
good.
Get them some,
some Alpha brain,
all that good shit.
Whatever you,
um,
you,
you do with your health,
uh,
the most important things.
You're dying.
You know what I mean?
It sounds like silly to preach that because everybody sort of should know what
at this stage of the life.
But you know,
eating healthy food will make a huge impact on the way your body feels.
It's,
it's just a fact.
It just,
we take it for granted cause other food is delicious.
Kentucky Fried Chicken fucking taste awesome.
But it's not that good for you.
And if you eat healthy and you,
especially if you supplement nutrients along with eating healthy,
your body will work better.
Your brain will work better.
It's a fact.
There's science behind it.
And the science behind Alpha brain is isolating all the nutrients that are
responsible for cognitive function.
All of the nutrients that stimulate your brain's production of all the good shit
that it needs to think good in scientific terms.
All of it is explained that on a.com if you your first 30 pills,
the by there's a 100% money back guarantee,
you don't have to even return the product to just say,
this shit didn't do anything for me.
No one's trying to rip you off.
We're just trying to need to sell you the best vitamins and nutrients and
exercise equipment and everything we're selling is,
we're just trying to find the best shit you can get the best.
We have the best blenders BLENDTEC blenders for,
um,
blending like Kale shakes and stuff like that and we sell them for a $200 less
than the manufactured,
uh,
retail suggested price.
Uh,
we,
we try to make everything as fair as possible.
All the Shit we're selling you is just the best shit possible at the most
reasonable price as possible.
This,
um,
uh,
Supplement company is,
I'm partially owned by me,
so I,
uh,
it's very important to me if the,
anything that we get involved with,
whether it's on it or teaching or whether it's audible.com.
It's all products that we believe in.
And if you go to on a.com use the code named Rogan.
You will save 10 off any and all
supplements for men.
All right,
I'm done.
It's not supplements from any
experience.
Powerful Greg.
Proops
dude,
great to see you man.
Thank you very much for coming down and doing this.
Awesome to be here.
Joe,
you said the dickens before.
You're the only person I even know that can say the Dickens and it towns.
It sounds perfect.
It fit right in there.
It meant to be said that way.
The Dickens.
I'm as loud as the Dickens.
Nobody's the dickens anymore and it's a quite a good one.
It's got chicken it,
which makes it king right off the tip.
And then you could sneak dick in.
Exactly here.
It's like showing bunt and swinging away as Dickins cause it comes back on you
really if you said,
if you say to someone you know loud as the Dickens,
they can't say anything like you'd say that to your grandmother and children.
That's amazing.
You Little Dickens.
That's so strange.
It's weird.
It's with this certain sounds that are like super offensive.
And if you sneak one out,
I mean we still agree to that.
It's so preposterous isn't it?
It's so fucking silly.
And why grant words that much demand and over your emotions and stuff,
like just the trigger of a sound is enough to make you fucking lose your shit
and like protest or write a letter.
Yeah.
It's like,
well we were almost agreeing that the heights that you could reach at your
worst,
at your nastiest to the way you feel about someone is not really reached with
regular language.
We have to reserve those extreme moments for one extreme word.
And if we don't do that,
we're never going to adequately portray how fucking mad we are.
True.
So if you use it too much,
I guess that's what's going on.
I'm guilty of that as much as any other comic.
I'm profane and I will say fuck too many times though,
during the setting of a nightclub,
how many act it's,
that's when you're,
you're having a few drinks or unwinding and you're like,
fuck this man.
That's where it's supposed to come out.
I think so too.
And I'm,
and that I had to do like a classy Gig in Chicago couple years ago.
I was playing at xannies and they go,
do you want to do this?
A Chicago Theater Gig?
Then,
you know,
the trip puts it on a Steadman is going to be there.
And,
uh,
what's his name from sticks,
you know,
a fucking Dennis right from sticks,
sticks.
But there you remember sticks.
I do remember them.
I can't remember what it,
that demo to.
Got To this.
And then they did.
Oh Wow.
[inaudible]
sticks.
The did shows up from steaks.
Has a fantastic,
used the word preposterous.
And minute ago he had a preposterous wife.
His wife was wearing a bubblegum pink and had a funny,
Penelope pitched up the hairdo and giant lips and airlines and was,
was like a delightful cartoon of what a rock star's wife would be in a conflict,
you know,
like,
like in a picture and a cartoon.
And,
um,
he was cool,
you know,
he looked good and,
uh,
I would get into there to do it.
And I'm being interviewed by the theater critic from the Tribune.
Right.
As an artist.
Right?
Because they're,
you know,
is the newspaper that,
so,
you know,
Joe Rogan,
let's talk about Jonathan,
you know,
it's not,
and it's polite company and then I have to do five.
And I realize as I looked through my act frantically outside,
I am profane in every set up,
every I'm going to have to calculatedly bank and work really hard to remove the
profane from every single line.
And then of course I did it and I probably,
I don't think I slipped,
but I get a joke about a bomb or something and they were a little more rich than
that at one point.
And I wanted that jokes really funny if you're blue collar and then they laughed
at the acknowledgement that that's gotta suck man.
That feeling well there was a nice crowd and I thought I'm an intelligent act,
you know what I mean?
I'd be ready to tight.
Why can't I leave five minutes of philosophy on these fuckers instead?
I,
Oh shit.
You know when you go to the fucking thing,
you know,
like you think really that's,
yeah.
Yes.
Cause I'm playing a club.
That's why I can't do anything other than the stand up.
Like I won't do standup in any other form.
I don't want to do it on a talk show.
I don't want to do it.
It's just doesn't seem like that.
Although I appreciate there's a different art form to crafting a really nice
seven minutes sat for like a tonight show set or something like that.
But I mean I know a lot of guys were awesome at that for me.
I can't,
it doesn't represent me.
It doesn't represent.
I think it's fantastic that you have that point of view.
I've done them over the years and it's never the best way.
I'm on TV it for four minutes.
I think I'm perplexing.
You know what I mean?
Like what,
why?
Well I think it was,
it's an awesome opportunity for comics to get seen and for the longest time it
was like the best one.
Like if you could get on Carson and Carson have you come down,
sit next to him on the couch,
like you are a fucking winner man.
And those who could attack comedy clubs from that.
But this is sort of a different time and now it's a very limiting thing and it
seems silly.
It seems the whole pageantry of it seems silly.
The band playing when people walk out and sit down and this weird conversation
in front of people.
I mean,
I know I enjoy doing them,
but they're an odd art form.
There's an odd fakery weirdness to the whole thing that's not necessary.
Well,
there's a almost a fifties in this about it.
It's one of the first TV shows,
you know,
because uh,
I don't know that there were lots of famous chat shows on the radio.
There was lots of humans,
variety shows and every other kind of show.
But I don't remember hearing about ones where people sat around and talked.
It seems to be a function of television because it's so cool as they say right
that year because you're kicked back in detached and watching it and you can sit
and watch people just go,
blah,
my book,
blah.
We shot a movie in Ireland.
It was really hard.
And that's entertainment,
but it hasn't been,
didn't like,
I don't know.
I would say Steve Allen kind of pioneered making it a thing on TV,
that exact format with the band and comics and sketches and you know,
yeah.
Uh,
and they've just stuck to it,
you know what I mean?
Then it's variations with any theme.
Everybody's done one,
but like you say,
it's funny like you in your show when you come on,
maybe there's music ms song you like or whatever.
Like we have theme songs for our shows,
uh,
on the podcast,
but when you'd come on on TV and they put a little butter,
pat and Bob,
Bob,
Joe Rogan,
he's going to be playing test case.
Yeah.
And Omaha.
You're like,
really?
Okay,
this is big.
This is,
I should have shined my shoes.
Yeah.
What is that Hokey fake thing that we do with that?
The hokey fake thing political guys do when they give speeches.
Yeah.
They'll like fake.
I love that though.
The whole pageant,
that's really old to me,
that hokey fake thing of his political speeches that now you're going back to
the dawn of Man,
right?
The first person that got up in front of everybody and went,
all right,
all right.
You know,
like I,
it's been a craft for so long and it's been refined in so many cultures that the
idea of putting forth this,
I got the word selfestry thrown at me yesterday.
I don't,
I'm not,
I don't kick it from,
what is that word?
It means a false philosophy.
Use using big words.
Like I'll throw an idea at you and back it up with a bunch of shit,
but it's not true at all.
That's my whole life.
Exactly.
The Guy tweeted me and said,
cause I do definitions of my show.
Like lately I've been doing political ones like democracy and you know,
like let's talk about with the d and feminism and things like that.
Like people say it a lot,
you hear it a lot,
but not everybody knows what it actually,
the dif,
the different,
you know the dictionary definition,
like we're,
we're supposed to start with it.
Right.
So he wrote,
how about selfestry?
And I wrote back,
what are you implying?
Right.
Just I looked it up and went,
you fucking Dick.
Don't,
don't shoot when in my heart.
That's a brutal one.
Yeah.
That's a clever person.
You could run into those clever fellows online,
someone,
and they're always waiting out there for you.
I get emails,
I make mistakes and my show,
right.
And people,
and I read the corrections people send me,
like I called Genghis Khan,
Jay Ganga [inaudible] because I'd read this book where it said it was kind of
pronounced like that.
And that dude wrote me who had lived in Mongolia.
He broke it down and gave me the syllable by still,
it's like Chingos,
Kotler,
whatever.
Oh,
he said it's more complicated,
but like Cha Ching is in like,
you know,
could chain,
like he broke the hole and then like,
yeah,
I lived in new lumber tour.
I taught French to the,
you know,
or whatever.
Like,
so you never get away with anything unless they've come up with some wild
fantasy that they've committed to an email.
It's doesn't seem like people would,
I trust it.
Most people are telling me the truth.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
I've,
I've always been fascinated by the noises that people make in their languages.
Like something like that.
Like sometimes you can just common that can,
that can be a word and it's so,
it's so alien from the w the English way of styling words.
It's so,
it's so strange.
So many varieties
all over the planet.
That's a really psychedelic thing when you're in another country and a,
you're around a bunch of people and they're saying things and you don't
understand.
Like Japan,
Japan was very psychedelic cause you just did another your other all the time
completely.
And um,
and you don't know the key because you don't even understand one,
you don't know anything about their culture.
Their culture is completely different than ours.
It's like things that we accept.
They don't,
it's,
it's very odd walking amongst them.
It was really strange.
It was like,
oh that's a truly different culture that just sort of evolved over there.
Do you think it's island thing?
I mean certainly could have been they there,
but they're starting to figure out now that there was so much travel that even
neanderthals were using boats and that they might've even been using boats
before.
People before homo.
I ate a subscribed to that and I will,
he furthered that theory and say that I think that all the preconceived notions
about people not intermingling with each other and meeting each other are a
nonsense and that people did it since people could make a boat basically.
And,
and that the coastlines of all the continents have risen.
They are,
they were lower tens of thousands of years ago and people lived in those places
and those places are covered with water.
So we cannot find all the stuff that was there.
I know it sounding like a Kook,
but I mean,
so we'll just cut a little water.
And I remember Kon Tiki and all that when they took the boat from Africa to
South America to prove you could do it,
you know,
they need to read about in like Egypt and they throw hide.
I'll sale that to South America a few times.
But when you think about like even the conquistadores or whatever,
those little caravels their aunt or whatever,
or not that sea worthy,
and in about three or four weeks they would make it and then they kind of,
you know,
get in and you think if they did it,
everybody did it.
The Polynesians went all the way up right to all I Hawaii,
which is not here anything.
The trade winds blow to it.
Right.
So that they could,
they took the trade,
went in and they gathered water on sales right at night with a gourd underneath
it dripped down and that's when they got fresh water on the road.
Oh my God.
And they brought pigs and whatnot.
Jesus Crunchyroll Catamaran.
What a fucking crazy experience that must've been.
Those people had balls you want to talk about balled.
She lost a lot of people on the way.
It took a while to get that established.
Yeah.
You couldn't just get that the first shot.
You're going to fuck that up.
Someone's going to die of thirst the first time the sun's gonna kill him or her
boat tips over.
There's a squad because it's the south.
It's the Pacific South Pacific man.
This,
the squall is stolen.
His fucking,
I've seen some fucking crazy storms in Hawaii.
Yeah,
because you know I was in New Zealand and the Maoris came down there and wiped
out whatever was there before them in the Middle Ages and then the white people
come up to them.
But they traveled extensively.
I mean po and Polynesians got around town.
They're like all up in the fucking,
yeah,
they were crazy.
Loked out people.
They make boats out of trees.
Just chop a fucking tree down hall of that bitch out navigating the,
now again,
they need the currents.
They knew they could read the breeze.
You know,
fucking how the air tasted.
They must,
the storm had to pass that shit down from generation to generation two.
It's an extraordinary,
no one talks about that.
People talk about the explorer is exploring,
which is is extraordinary.
But what are the people who settled Hawaii or any of those far flung places like
that is an undertaking.
Fucking bad.
Asses what fucking incredible bad acids.
That's why Hawaiians,
it's so tough.
Yeah.
They are like Hawaiian,
like Hawaii is one of the last places where people have like regular street
fights.
They filmed them all the time in Hawaii.
People you,
you see fights in like a restaurant.
You'll be sitting in.
Two guys are like,
Hey,
you want to nick?
You know they're aggressive.
None.
They're aggressive.
You have to be to get an a fucking boat and in a row out to the middle of the
ocean hoping you're going to find something.
Those are the most loked out people alive with your little idle on your deck
singing songs and shit.
Coddling fucking casting for fish,
right?
Trying to catch fish.
Gosh,
whole time you find a fucking island and there's no islands between Hawaii and
anything.
It's about what?
The miles from the nearest land mass 2,500 miles going.
How fast too?
Yes.
Can you even go to catch the fucking wind and you better how that your back and
just sort of floating around out there.
You're not really going to get like any good pace going well link is it take to
get a sailboat across the,
like the modern sail boats that can do it fairly quick.
I'm reading this Columbus Book to be the complete board about it and he,
they said he got over in four weeks on the last one on the fourth journey and
like 15 though to whatever and four weeks in a care about and a fleet,
three,
four caravels.
And um,
he,
uh,
the,
the author says a sailor today would be hard pressed to make that kind of time.
Like he's made time because that thing they said about Columbus for all of his
shortcomings and,
and you know,
his ego,
uh,
he could dead rec in like nobody in the business.
Like he didn't use instruments,
instruments apparent according to this author fucking that he'd take out the sex
and he couldn't do a good reading.
And like,
then he'd go like north by north and they'd fucking wall.
They catch him,
you know,
like he was that navigator.
He found thousands of islands in the Caribbean.
Like he found every island in the Caribbean.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yes.
Just by fucking sailing every night to a different place like he was that,
how much do we know about the,
the accuracy of the horrible things that were said about them.
Like the,
the most recent stuff,
like when we were in high school,
we never really heard anything bad about Columbus service
missions.
But then I,
when I was in college,
I had heard something about there,
there was something about bashing babies and killing babies and all the
different things that they did to
him.
You didn't want to see them around anymore.
Well,
there's that.
They certainly did that.
There's certainly that within a couple of generations they'd killed every Indian
in the career.
There are no Indians in the Caribbean,
so they too are in South American,
Central American.
They just showed up and just started ganking people.
I mean,
what happened?
Did they,
did they,
did they find conflict with the native Americans or where they just touch on a
great administrator and he did was not a great empathetic reader of people.
Like his skill was that he had unshakable faith in his mission,
right?
But everywhere he ran into with the Indians and stuff,
it was,
he was contrary,
right?
Sometimes he was benevolent and gave them gifts other times.
It all right,
everybody bring me gold and everybody has to wear a necklace to say they brought
me into gold and you have to bring this much a month or I'm going to fucking be
you and make you a slave to a whole island of people.
And then for 50,000 Indians,
by some count historical count,
uh,
to committed suicide rather than be under the Spaniards Dominion.
And this is before there's even colonies.
There's like he,
his calls and 50,000,
this is the beginning of it all.
And uh,
then they were sending them back to slaves.
I mean,
imagine though that the high point of his life is obviously at the after the
first one that they were about to meet me,
right?
And they saw it in the night and he was a Dick,
a sailor on one of the other vessels,
saw it first.
And he claimed he saw the light.
At the same time,
there was a light on an island and they'd been at sea for like three or four
weeks and the guys are kind of flipping out because no one had ever been over
the edge of the world,
right.
Right there.
The first boats that went over the edge of the world,
like they were going west.
West,
west knows what the fuck.
So we don't,
didn't we have China?
That's what they thought.
Right?
So crazy.
She gets back after that and then she leaves a bunch of guys there.
I'm not kidding on the first missing leaves,
like 40 guys in,
in Hispaniola.
Oh my thoughts off back to Spain.
What happens to those guys?
Are they all died,
the Indians killed them all,
man.
They started raping.
They started raping the women and taking guys as slaves.
They started like,
eh,
but the Vix,
the cultural exchange and the echo exchange begins immediately,
right?
They had hammocks.
We'd never seen a hammock.
They'd never seen a candle.
They had tobacco and potatoes and tomatoes and you know,
uh,
Turkeys.
They changed the world.
Right?
And,
uh,
that we,
the Europeans,
how'd you know,
guns and steel and pigs and disease.
How long did it take a,
after they arrived,
before the Indians killed them all?
Well on that one they left them there and went back to Spain.
So those guys just kind of had a drunk village for a while and then the Indians
kind of got them.
And then there were Koreans who feels so weird.
Lake Indians,
it's such,
he gave them program.
That's the his legacy man.
So,
so powerful whether he's a villain or whatever.
And of course he is the only,
obviously in some ways,
but like if it wasn't him it would have been,
this is a terrible excuse,
but he,
someone was coming was coupled.
Cause within 30 years every buddy came,
it's an,
it's crazy how much and then the Dutch and the French and then you know how much
more gangster one part of the world was,
uh,
there was race baby,
they were racing and it was really fun,
like in like a Roman ideal of like for the bounty man [inaudible] for the glory
of the Empire in the church.
And for fucking find whatever you can and take it in our name and gifts with
Blah commissions.
The king and Queen of Glorious Catholic Spain,
welcome,
you know,
join us.
That's what they were.
And then of course it always goes horribly wrong.
The greed,
they wanted gold.
Even Columbus won a gold and they want to go and there's no golden,
the Caribbean.
It was always those,
those scenes in the movies where a guy would ride up on a horse with a decree.
They did open it up and then they'd have to figure out and they killed him.
And then we're at war.
What a bunch of crazy ass people.
It's nuts.
And you really stop and think about that.
That's how the new and the old world came together.
That's what fascinates me.
I mean it's,
it's not so much that I think Columbus is the greatest person or road.
It's,
it's the,
the exchange.
This is the first big moment.
Yeah.
The Vikings came over.
They did.
And maybe even Saint Patrick,
who was it?
Some Irish saint came over and a leather boat,
they said of leather boat,
a leather.
But from Ireland,
cotton,
the land and fucking hit like Canada.
Oh my God,
I'll leather the vikings,
you know,
cause the vikings were mad sailors.
They,
you know,
they could have made it to North America and they made some pretty fairly
sophisticated boats with a time and they could go rose and sales.
Right.
You're never bit calmed.
You can fucking crack out the rows and Jesus glueless crafty votes.
The only danger is of course getting wiped out,
you know,
in a storm.
They would take them over land.
When they did invade places they,
they like dragged him into Russia and then went up to fucking bowl.
Got of Moscow and stuff.
They,
yeah,
the Vikings captured Paris.
He went up the sand.
Oh,
you have answered what that time Lester.
Yeah,
just boats full of boosters would show up big with belief systems and you know,
and mushrooms.
I was going to say that the Vikings are definitely the most psychedelic of all
the Arab tribes.
And uh,
do they know what mushroom they took?
Yeah,
I'm sure they do.
We could look it up.
Probably.
I want to say that it was the Ama Nita Musky area.
The would that one that always gets connected to religion and Santa Claus and
all of their red and white one.
I want us to sound a little cap with a white top.
No,
it's a,
it's a big red thing with white
spots all over.
It looks like salad.
Yeah,
it's Murray brothers.
It looks like Santa Clause.
Do you know the correlation between the Amanita miscarry and saying,
oh,
you gotta see this?
Bryan Pope put,
just pull up Amma,
Nita Mascara and Santa Claus just for like an image of a what the mushroom looks
like if people haven't seen it before.
It's a bright red and white and it in the eyes of many people who have examined
it.
It represents Santa Claus and the reason why Santa Claus has this red and white
outfit is cause that's the colors of the enemy to emanate and miscarry and
mushroom.
The reason why the Christmas tree,
which is a coniferous tree has these brightly covered packages underneath it is
because these mushrooms have a microrisal relationship with these,
these trees in there.
They look like bright packages and they show up in their bright shiny packages
of red and white underneath the trees.
The way they dried them out as they would either pick them off and put them in
the tree so they would dry in the sun,
which is just like you're waiting,
decorate the tree.
Or they would hang them in front of the fireplace to dry them out,
which is exactly what the stockings over the fireplace and why the fucking
stockings are red and white.
That's the mushroom [inaudible].
Did it pull up?
You just had an image of it,
right,
Brian?
That's it right there.
Yeah.
There's,
there's a,
a bunch of images.
The older images of Santa Claus with that mushroom,
you see that the older you go when it goes,
you'd go back to like really ancient depictions of these mushrooms.
The older you go,
the more often you see these mushrooms around elves and Christmas tree,
a Christmas cards and things along those lines,
these mushrooms around Santa Claus.
So it was a direct connection.
They were drawing fucking mushrooms and elves for Christmas cards.
So at one point in time people were still connected to this idea.
If they've lost it,
the end of Nina,
what do you call it?
I'm gonna need a Mascara mushroom.
There was this,
yeah,
there was a,
to be the one that vikings you're taking,
right?
They have the tree where shipping all that too.
There was a scholar named John Marco Allegro who was one of the guys,
um,
who was a decipher the dead sea scrolls and he wrote two books about it.
One of them's called the the Dead Sea Scrolls in the Christian myth.
And the other one is called the sacred mushroom and the cross.
And it's all about how the entire Christian religion was based on psychedelic
mushroom eating and sex rituals and the fertility rituals.
Quiet right now.
He was sex.
It was all that and mushroom.
This,
that mushroom was on the cover of the book,
the Amanita miscarrying mushroom.
Yeah.
That this mushroom,
like they would find out about how to use it and they would find out about how
to prepare it and then it would give them this unbelievable psychedelic
experience.
So they hid all of the,
all of the ways of preparing it and finding it.
And apparently it's a very tricky mushroom.
It's,
it's,
it,
it's variable genetically.
It's variable.
Seasonally.
It's like it doesn't always give you the experience.
So you have to figure out how to find it from what,
what area it has.
Some of them will knock your Dick into the dirt.
Right.
And some of them do nothing but make you sweat.
It's a,
it's a weird machine.
So the idea is that they hid all the information inside.
These old stories
can ask a question.
The,
so when you say all Christianity,
do you mean like European Christianity where the mushroom exists or did it exist
in the Middle East as well?
Well,
this is the Dead Sea scrolls were all found in Kumaris.
So that's where they were writing this stuff supposedly.
Um,
so in,
at least in that area,
in Israel,
they were taking mushrooms according to them allegro.
But see allegro was the only scholar on the,
the,
there was a list of scholars that were hired to decipher the Dead Sea Scrolls.
He was the only one that that was an agnostic.
He wasn't ordained minister.
But then in studying theology he just said,
well,
this is kind of silly.
Obviously there's some you just crazy stories and let's just get to the root of
all this and find out where this all comes from.
By chance.
Was He also the only professor that also took mushrooms?
I don't think the crazy thing is,
I don't think he did.
He was a really a straight laced scholar.
I know.
Get to Santa Claus jail.
Well,
Santa Claus being,
how does it get all the way down to the same,
I understand that the colors and the tree and everything is he,
they always give us this bullshit story about Saint Nicholas fruits from Turkey
and yeah,
like,
like Wikipedia and everything says that,
you know,
there's a couple of different versions and one is from Germany,
one's from,
yeah,
they're the Siberian one.
Uh,
the reindeer.
The thing about the reindeer,
one of the things about the rangers are reindeer love to eat.
Amanita miscarry and mushrooms.
So much so.
Yeah.
So much so that when they have a shamonic rituals in the,
the,
um,
sweat lodges and they will have these rituals and they take these mushrooms,
they'll step out to urinate the reindeer.
We'll knock them over to get at their urine.
Snow.
Wow.
Yeah.
They love it.
They love,
and why the fuck are these reindeer flying but dear,
why are they flying the,
he's the Sharman who is red and white.
Like the Amnio Mascara mushroom is sitting in a carriage and he's fucking flying
with all the bunch of deer who on mushrooms?
Mushroom.
How,
how clear do they have to make the myth that these rangers are high?
Wow.
I have to read this clear.
It's really his name.
John Marco.
Allegra.
It's really hard to understand.
I don't have any background in languages,
so,
and listening to or reading how he broke it all down,
apparently it's very controversial.
Yes,
I can imagine.
Yeah.
But the fact remains is like this guy was a,
uh,
you know,
he's a legit brilliant scholar and an agnostic.
And if you have one guy out of a list of religious vi Kooks that are reading
ancient shit,
hoping to find,
you know,
Jesus special friends list or whatever the fuck your tribe,
they're not captains watch,
you're not going to be willing to consider anybody's alternative ideas.
So I dunno if he's right,
but it's fascinating.
It is fascinating.
I mean,
cause I was in aid,
I,
I've,
you know,
I've heard about the Saint Nicholas and all that and I,
and I was at that little chapel where he supposedly was and everything and it
was like you don't get a big Santa Claus wintertime,
you know,
Ho Ho,
Ho drink a coca cola,
feel it sits to me.
The leap is really,
you know,
other than he was the local guy who gave gifts and whatnot.
Yeah.
Hold on.
Fuck knows where all those stories came from.
So fascinating.
I thought flying reindeer,
we're an invention of,
what's his name?
Clement more or whatever.
Who wrote,
was it night before Christmas?
It could have been
maybe,
but maybe tapped into something that you knew about flying range.
Well,
I think that he'd heard a story from Europe.
There's so many connections between this mushroom and Santa Claus.
It's almost like,
it's almost silly.
Yeah.
But there's just like things like if you think about,
you know,
like the pink Floyd,
a wizard of Oz total,
it's the same shit.
You're going to find that something in anything
that's so true.
But this one is really the whole story.
Like Santa Claus coming down the chimney.
That's how the Shaman used to get into the houses.
When they made the shamanic rituals illegal,
he used to sneak in because everybody was on the ground watching the door.
So they would throw their fucking sack,
a mushrooms over the chimney and they would climb down into these people's
houses.
Yeah,
I mean this,
there's so many connections between the whole Santa Claus myth and the this,
this,
this mushroom,
the ritual of taking this mushroom,
especially in Siberia,
which is the fucking north.
Oh yeah.
They'll essentially,
it's a,
it's what people look at it as.
Yeah.
At the end of the earth.
No question.
If you were living
Siberia and you found a mushroom,
they make you trip your fucking balls off.
How much they warm.
Yeah.
Life would be so much more awesome.
Icon that mushroom,
the trees and the birds.
Oh yeah,
that's,
that's what kept them alive.
They were there were trip their balls off every few months.
Yeah.
It seems like a desperate,
it always seemed like the most desperate place.
I mean,
when you,
when you lend your name to the bad patch of land in everyone's mind,
even when you go to a restaurant,
I know my wife,
if they put some more bad,
I'm like,
hey,
why are we in Siberia?
It's always Siberia.
Siberia you have anytime.
It was a Russian movie,
like a James Bond movie and the Russian spy got sent to Siberia.
Yeah.
Fucked out there.
I mean,
you're going to die.
Yeah.
If you,
if you could have a nice mushroom trip every couple of months,
keep you going though and take those eight tiny reindeer.
They save the dolphins.
Exactly.
Fucking how cold does it get up there?
It gets really cold.
Hundred degrees below zero.
Right.
It's horrible.
And they're swimming in oil.
So they've saved themselves,
you know,
oh
you saved yourself,
but you're stuck up there.
Yeah,
but you know what,
there's a documentary.
I say that there's a great documentary.
I just take that back.
I have to take it back.
Um,
a Werner Herzog's happy people.
A life on the Thai guy,
I think it's called and it's about these people that live up there in Siberia
and they are all trappers right there apparently.
Like they're like,
oh healthy.
Everyone's happy.
There's no,
no one has all day running around.
Yeah,
exercising.
No one has any like depression,
no psychological disorders.
It's a real happy culture.
And they showed them all get together and they follow them with the camera and
they followed them to their,
they're trapping routes where they would stay by themselves for months and
they're all fucking really happy.
It was like,
it was weird.
They get together,
they would be eating and laughing and all happy.
And at the end of the day,
if we have really our temporary beings there,
they are actually doing it right.
We're doing it wrong.
Well,
they don't ever come home and go,
I can't believe I got fucking passed over for a promotion.
Yeah.
Xanax and a wine.
I want to one line,
I want to watch a fucking real housewives,
Dexter.
No,
no,
they don't do that.
And they live forever and they probably drink moderately and probably are
exercising all day every day.
Yeah.
And they're eating Caribou,
you know,
and the reading like the healthiest shit you can eat,
like fresh game and vegetables that they grow.
It's fascinating,
man.
They're so much,
I haven't seen that one,
but I did see one recently.
My wife rented a,
and I can't think of the bloody name of it.
Oh,
you might have to look it up,
Brian.
It's about,
uh,
the caves in France where the,
all the Chris dark paintings are the ones they found like 20 years ago,
you know,
that had the horses that are the ones that predate.
Yeah.
And they're in motion.
You know,
in one room is like one guy's left hand like a zillion times.
He put it everywhere and it pops up a few other places in the cave.
And they're extensive.
And,
uh,
they found them by accident,
all of us,
but hurts.
It goes in because they're closing them off except for study.
And he said his crew goes in and he,
uh,
he shoots it and it is,
Eh,
you know,
I'll give him what,
oh,
what's the end of the,
uh,
it's called the Cave of dreams.
That's it.
Is that it cave of dreams.
But I'm always trying to think,
you know,
suppose about your singing.
What was it like to live when gangsters came up in boats?
You know,
imagine,
I don't know,
50,000,
100,000,
200,000 years ago,
and you were living in a cave and Lee were law,
much like those choppers in Siberia because he's now you're down to,
you know,
you're in a boat,
you probably have fire,
maybe you have.
But to see the sophistication of the drawings,
the animation and the depiction of the animals in the imagination,
and to see this on a wall from 30,000 years ago,
it's the connection that you know,
it,
it is just yesterday and it's never different.
All this technical stuff and all the wonder of your phone and the apps that you
can download is nothing,
uh,
in
the,
I don't mean that you should just not use it.
I mean,
the connection of,
of people,
like you say a to what's happening is as a little more profound than,
and that's what always gets overlooked until he's like,
oh,
well that was then,
and people didn't want to know about like a couple of years ago,
you know?
Yeah.
No kidding.
I don't think you should dwell on the past,
but of course I do.
Uh,
but you know,
really found it fascinating to see the,
the human touch.
That's what gets you.
But I don't think a guy like you or a girl like me,
it would be happy if all of a sudden we had a live like a Siberian trailer.
No,
man.
Are you kidding me?
I'm such a sissy.
I,
okay.
No booty.
Wouldn't we want to do the thing that seems to make you the most happy?
No,
no,
we're not.
We're not like that anymore.
I can't do it in Paris.
You know what I mean?
Like cell phones got this close or what know,
looking back,
is that what it is?
We,
we ate the apple man.
It's over.
There seems to be no looking back,
it's like we want to,
we want to drive old cars.
Oh,
they're fucking cool.
Imagine that day 68 corvette.
People stop and look at it as it goes by.
It's like a time machine.
You're looking at an MRI machine.
We,
we want to,
but we wouldn't be happy back then.
Now.
I always say it wasn't better.
It was just then,
but those tag up people are right now.
Absolutely they are.
But [inaudible] article about people keep losing live on an island in Greece who
purportedly lived to be a hundred and all it turns out,
of course they didn't flooded their age when the study was done years ago,
but they are living to the nineties and,
and close to a hundred,
almost all of them.
And it's,
you know,
they go and visit each other.
They don't watch a lot of tele.
They'd fucking eat olive oil.
They likely have a glass of wine sunset,
you know,
like walking around the garden.
Oh,
it's hilly,
it's fuck.
And they're old and they whoop their ass up the hill all the time.
I bet that's big in and of itself.
Just walking up hills.
Yeah,
it's the villages there and you were,
that's fucking exercise.
Most people don't realize like it you,
you had to like,
it's not,
they're not going hiking,
that's their life.
And they're doing it every day.
Go to see your friend and you'll have tea or whatever,
coffee and they have vegetable gardens and whatnot.
And he was like,
they were describing in life and it was like the kind of thing you pay for it to
go away for it to your wife on a weekend,
you know,
that has to be to look at the Mediterranean and drink wine at sunset and you're
like,
I kicked around in the garden if that was part of it.
But do you think you'd be happy living there now?
I'd be bored senseless after a while.
You'd have your studies,
right?
And you'd have your,
you know,
your computer if it worked,
if it worked there on a remote island in the Mediterranean.
But you would have to be into like either starting a cult or doing some hardcore
drugs.
That's the only way you would really write the book,
Joe.
That's where you write the book.
Fuck,
that's who's going to read it?
You're trapped.
Well,
you got to leave.
You have to get someone to deliver the book flow.
Have you been following the John Mccaffrey thing?
You know what that is?
No.
John McCaffrey is the virus king.
The guy who created McCaffrey antivirus.
Well,
he
apparently is uh,
quite a character and uh,
he started a business.
This is what this is the beginning of it started a business where he had low
flying planes.
Uh,
they would do this sport where they fly like really low to the ground and
maneuver around.
Well,
yeah,
one of the planes crashed.
Somebody died.
So he got rid of all of his assets in America and transferred them over to
Billy's.
So he's in believes now he lives in Belize and he has a compound and believes
and in that compound he cooks up bath salts.
So you know there's different chemicals that are being sold as bath salts.
These various legal forms of some sort of crazy drug.
They're legal,
the by loopholes Ho he's,
he's like cooking them and like free basing them and getting them down to like
the,
he's like purifying them and doing all these stuff.
No,
no.
He has labs.
He has labs in his jungle,
a fucking,
he has photos and he takes photos of all the shit and puts it online and he
keeps a blog on too.
I'm sorry everybody,
I don't know,
something from the hinterland or something like that is the blog and he just
started the blog.
It's fascinating because the dude is on the lamb because his neighbor is dead.
His neighbor got shot in the head and his neighbor who he believes the McCaffrey
beliefs,
this neighbor poisoned his dogs cause he had a bunch of dogs bark all the time.
He shot him.
So he believes that we are,
I don't know if he shot him,
he says he didn't.
But the Belize government says he did and he says this is not about that.
This is a just,
there are a bunch of criminals and they're,
you know,
they're corrupt and they're going after him for no reason and he had nothing to
do with it and he was fearing for his own life.
He thought they were out to get him before they shot his.
They think that he said they set him up,
they killed his neighbor to set him.
That's his take on it,
but it's no doubt about that.
The dude is cooking bass off.
He's got,
he's got a 17 year old girlfriend.
Yes,
he does.
He's 62 or something like that.
This is some deep,
he's crazy and he is breaking bad.
Yeah.
He's,
he's a character in breaking bad.
Wow.
He's a character to go look it up.
It's a fucking amazing story because he's still,
he's still in the country.
He's hiding.
He's on the lamb there.
They're trying to find him and try him for murder and he's blogging at the same
time as any compound in the laser.
The 17 year old girlfriend cooking salt.
Yeah.
I,
they day he escaped that compound.
Oh,
he got out and now he's on the lamb.
They don't know where he is,
but while he's out,
he's blogging.
I didn't even know that you can take bath salts.
Really?
I've used them so frequently in my bath.
You know,
the bath salts,
you know the comment.
Do you know what that is?
Well,
I've hear about people taking them and doing,
committing dreadful acts and whatnot.
Well,
it's just,
it's,
they've taken some form of like math or some,
some intense form of narcotic drug,
something,
and they'll change it,
like change a molecule,
added oxygen molecule,
do whatever to it that they have to do in order to make it a different chemical
classification.
Then it becomes legal as long as they sell it,
not for human consumption.
So they sell it as bath salts.
So they sell it and you know,
everybody knows what the fuck it really is.
But what is it?
It's some meth flight drug.
Oh,
so it's speeding.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's not like DMT or something.
No,
no,
no.
It's horrible.
It's a terrible drug,
supposedly.
Supposedly.
But that was the other thing.
Um,
uh,
McCaffrey was talking about how his form of it that he's been cooking up,
makes a four hypersexuality God,
yes.
He was talking about people rubbing their penises,
Ra and then just having monkey sex like for hours and hours.
So he just,
you picture this cracked out 60 year old dude hanging with a 17 year old girl in
the jungle on this fucking insane drug concoction that he's cooked up in his own
lab and he's a brilliant guy.
It's,
it's like he's a brilliant guy.
Gone Mad.
It's really,
it's really fascinating man.
That is,
that's extraordinary.
Yeah.
Let me,
let me pull up what this drug actually is.
Just so we
substituted,
Catherine owns,
which have similar effects of amphetamine and cocaine.
The white crystals resemble legal bathing products like Epsom salts and are
called bath salts with the packaging,
often stating not for human consumption and an attempt to avoid the prohibition
of drugs,
but chemically have nothing to do with actual bath salts.
Yeah.
So there's just something they've created in a lab.
It's like they figured out a way around it.
It's amazing,
man.
People are Gross,
you know,
people are so gross,
they'll,
they'll spend their time to come up with some new form of meth and then just
release it in some legal loophole in like laugh all the way.
There's a fucking demons.
People who sell that are demons.
Yeah.
That lets the,
isn't that all the um,
people have psychotic episodes and go furiously mental and kill people by
People's faces off and shit?
Well they said that that guy,
they said he tested positive for marijuana.
That was one of the things that they were saying,
which I found hilarious because the,
what they didn't say it's,
which is really kind of fucking creepy.
They didn't say in the news report that they can't really test for bath salts.
Like most,
most bath salts,
they don't,
they don't have like,
they don't have a marker for them.
They're a bunch of different,
there's a bunch of different kinds too.
So it's like,
just because like he didn't test for heroin or didn't test for crystal method,
method,
whatever it is.
That doesn't mean he wasn't on mass salts.
Like they said he wasn't on bass halls.
They said he was on marijuana.
But that's like such,
that's such shitty reporting.
Like you have tell the truth that it's,
it's hard to find out if people were on the show rumor or the,
the accepted knowledge was that he was on dos salts and that's why he was so
psychotic.
Yeah.
But that's not what they,
they got when they did the,
Oh,
of course.
Not The chemical tests on him after he is,
well,
if it doesn't show up,
it's not going to be,
Brian doesn't think the cop should have killed the guy.
Right.
Isn't that the one that we disagreed when the guy was eating the guy's face?
You,
you didn't think that the cop should have shot him.
Was it you or was it Duncan?
Duncan?
Duncan didn't think the cops should have shot the guy and was like,
[inaudible] face man murdering somebody.
Yeah.
That's murdering somebody.
Natalie,
that like that is such a fucking creepy way to go about it.
Eating someone's face.
And I think that cops a lot of,
shoot,
you just me,
I'm old school.
Uh,
yeah.
If it's happening to me and let me put it that way,
please go ahead and shoot that guy.
Jesus Christ.
Seeding faces might be good.
So this John McCaffrey guy,
he's,
um,
he's actually got a blog while he's on the lamb.
So there's this crazy government in Billy's is looking for him like they sending
like according to him,
he hasn't to soldiers to his house.
I don't,
I don't know man.
I don't know what,
cause he's gotten that name.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't know how it works.
The least has been a haven forever for people from the states.
Hasn't really a lot of ex pats.
Yeah.
I think confederates,
that type of thing.
It's,
you know,
I said rum runner kind of,
I think you can end up in Belize.
So it's just like one of those wild places.
I mean,
I don't,
I've been once,
but I didn't really go to like,
you know,
smuggler's cove to story.
So fascinating.
When a really smart guy goes off the rails,
we're waiting for Bill Gates to like build a giant veranda.
Have you ever seen the,
uh,
descriptions of a gates home?
Oh yeah.
Right.
It's insane.
He was incredible.
Right.
And everything he talked to the maximum,
you can just go brewer and shit flies.
Or he puts a clip on when he walks in and as he enters into rooms,
they adjust to his liking.
Yeah,
that's fucking,
that's gangster.
That's really gangster.
When you're bill gates though,
anything less would be ridiculous.
I mean,
yeah,
no,
he has to do it.
William Randolph Hearst to whatever.
We're building a giant palace for yourself.
But how much do you bet his toilet crashes all the time.
His Twitter crashes.
Toilet toilet crashes.
Why do you think?
Because it's always sits like windows and stuff,
so it's all probably just,
Oh
this is actually toilet was the shower stopped honey?
Yeah,
it's a kind of virus.
He's someone that like if your computer fucks up and having him in the house I
think would be super handy.
It would definitely help me cause he didn't be like,
Oh,
let me just call somebody.
You know,
you're going,
fuck,
how come my email's not working for like a day?
He's just like,
buy Mac.
The number of viruses that exist,
computer viruses that exists are fucking terrifying.
If you really stop and think about how many assholes out there figured out a way
to crack into people's computers,
like how many hundreds of thousands of people did it and you're,
there's schools of there.
He gets scam emails,
you know,
hey man,
from my friends.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I've got them from me.
That's gotten emails from me.
Right.
What is this?
That's a weird,
it's so crazy.
What are you doing man?
I don't know.
I was just sitting there.
Maybe it was crazy.
I your crazy.
I didn't know what to say on there.
I saw like emails from my website.
I was like,
how is that even possible?
That's crazy.
I don't know what it actually says when you look into it.
I don't click on them,
but just the idea that someone can do that at this John McAfee thing.
Would you want to end up riding wild and some tropical place at the end of here?
I can have Jackson Fun.
No,
it seems like another novel.
Yeah,
that seems like you are.
Just trying to burn out that you try to just fizzle out.
You just trying to,
you realize the end is near and so you're just going to go out guns blazing,
rubbing your dick raw.
Right.
Smoke it.
Bath salts,
bagging,
17 year olds.
I mean,
it's pretty wild though.
It's the stuff of legend.
It's,
that's like one of those things.
Or if I did,
if I didn't know about it,
I'd be angry if you knew about it and you didn't tell me I want to,
I want to know what he's doing.
You know,
he's a crazy guy and he's a fucking really rich guy too.
He sold his company to Microsoft for over a billion dollar.
Oh my God.
So He's just funded.
Yeah.
So this crazy ass hole had like this compound and he was having low flying
plans.
I mean,
just stop and think about how fucking bananas you have.
The thing that of course someone died,
someone dies.
Yeah.
And then they're selling them.
So he just fucking Ballz he's nuts,
man.
I don't know if he killed his neighbor,
but,
uh,
not to,
it's probably pretty obvious.
The Colonel Kurtz thing.
Yeah.
Well I think whenever a guy like starts his own thing in a small country and
picks a 17 year old as his,
uh,
his companion.
That's right.
Yeah.
You're,
you're really,
you're going for a low bar son.
No,
no,
no.
Here,
that's out of bounds.
And you're really old for a 17 year old man.
That's kind of your old for 17 year old if you're 25 minutes.
Yeah.
That's Kinda crazy.
Well,
it's just one of those stories and I just,
I'm,
I'm fascinated by people off the rails when,
when we realized that these patterns that we file,
that we don't have to follow them and oftentimes people just say fuck this and
just completely exit the normal train of behavior,
like fascinated by all the dictators chore.
Yeah.
Because they don't,
you know,
there's no rules.
They kill people personally in front of other people and then go,
this is how it goes.
And then that's how they start their gig and then you take over and you punish
in you whatever.
Yeah.
We're always fascinated by the ones throughout history and most recent ones
like,
like Hussein and his sons used to scare the shit out of me when you would hear
the stories of what they did and you know that all those stories are not made
up.
No feeding people to dogs,
Dude.
It's old time stuff.
Yeah.
They would take people,
just random people and like girls were about to get married.
They would steal them from the guy,
throw the guy,
feed him to dogs,
fuck the girl raper and then feed her dogs.
They liked horror.
They did shit like that on a regular basis.
That dogs that were eating people.
Yeah.
Mother fuckers,
man.
I mean the,
the,
that something can happen in,
in the human mind where it allows them to become so vicious and detached from
other people suffering to the,
to,
to the point where they actually enjoy it.
Like that scares the fuck out of us.
Absolutely.
And that power that,
that informs all that you have so much power that no one can gain.
Say You,
I'm going to do that kind of shit.
And if you didn't like it.
Yeah,
it's fucking crazy that we could go that way.
It's,
it's like the human brain needs a really good directions manual,
you know,
a really good one.
You have to like get a degree in before you can live,
you know what I mean?
He really should.
We should take all babies and quarantine them from the rest of society and raise
them,
raise them,
then examine people,
get their kids on a and a emoney and the and that has a mushroom farm and while
while the kid is going through school,
the parents are being reconditioned program to learn how to fly like a ranger
and then run in the jungle later with the young,
the,
I think there's probably a bunch of cultures,
a punch of ancient cultures that did a lot of mushrooms.
If you really look at like cattle worship and stuff like that.
I would think psychoactive substances were instrumental in almost every,
oh,
not to be boring,
but I just read about in the Columbus book,
the Taino,
Indians used to blow a powder,
a certain seed and put it in a pipe and blow it up each other's nose and have
mystical trans experience,
psychedelic experiences.
What was the,
what was the stuff and if I could remember,
I would tell you gel.
It's a,
some seed that grows on the islands in the Caribbean.
I could get,
I could email you later when I go back and look at the book.
But uh,
the Spanish took,
took note of that and their ceremonies and how they danced and what they wore
and how they conducted these giant things with the priests and they were taking
drugs in front of them and you know,
you blew it up your nose and once you got a big hit in each,
in Australia,
you know.
Yeah.
There's other cultures that have done that too.
They take like tubes and they stick them,
he chose nostrils and they'll,
they'll blow this stuff,
uh,
into each other who really like,
and it's like super painful experience and then it goes right to your brain.
Yeah.
And apparently it's a,
some of them are DMT based solely.
Yeah.
Some of them are having a,
I think
it's called equal.
Hey is one of those a nasal,
a blast and drugs.
And the problem is with the deforestation in the Amazon that like these people
that know how to make that stuff and know exactly what the lore behind it all
is.
They're going away.
They're,
they're being,
they're being pushed out.
There's so much logging going on and it's really,
it's an Amazon store.
Everything and all the psychoactive drugs are there that can help us and hear us
and make us at least make us have a good time.
Yeah.
At least in America,
I think the whole continent with CIC,
psychoactive drugs,
weed and you know,
but definitely mushrooms.
And
I did a tour,
Cheech and Eatsa with a professor and a,
it was really cool because they,
you could hire a local professor and he,
one of the things that he talked about that I'd never heard anybody have like a
real scholar talk about was how active actively they took psychoactive drugs and
he was talking about how this was a,
they had a chamber and he said,
and they would go in here and they would take various psychoactive drugs and he
thinks that some of them are mushrooms,
some of them were some,
there was a root or something that contained my surgical [inaudible] acid.
There's a few different ones that they had figured out could make you trip,
but they would have regular psychedelic rituals and to us that sounds ridiculous
because it's like,
listen,
stop.
All that bullshit,
which you need to do is you need to go to fucking school and you need to get to
go to college,
get a good job.
Well,
we don't understand is there was no school before this.
You're talking about people that literally created the first structures as far
as we know that would like that near them and the way they were inspired might
have been through psychedelic drugs.
It might be that these people were,
were given these ideas through these drugs and that's why they're so similar to
other cultures where they also use psychedelic drugs and make these crazy stone
structures that mimic the cosmos.
It's really fascinating.
Well,
I think it,
it does and I think that's why it's such an integral and it profound.
That's why it's always part of the religious culture too.
It wasn't a recreational thing like let's go get fucked up.
They,
uh,
the Indian societies are completely prescribed by religion that John went off in
the morning and everybody got up and people went to religious school and priests
who are the hierarchy and the things you're talking about with those taking the
mushrooms.
I think that the intuition that they derived at the very beginning when they
first took them and how they were able to refine it and cultivate it,
like you say,
and find out which ones did,
which they absolutely leads to the creative process and that's why they
incorporated it into their
system.
You know,
it's amazing.
Europeans just don't,
you know,
it was the alcohol by then,
by the time they met in the Middle Ages.
It's,
that's why they were so savage that alcohol based cultures and cans and liquor,
baby guns,
liquor and conquer.
That's a totally different attitude than the psychedelic cultures to come to.
It's just the,
yeah,
for sure.
Druid certainly get it going and Oh yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of mushrooms in Europe,
apparently.
Any,
I think anywhere where like rains a lot.
Oh yeah.
And then if it,
if it doesn't,
I don't know.
I mean I was in Morocco and uh,
I didn't get that.
They were,
I'm sure they had second thoughts,
but you can eat Hashi share,
whatever.
You know what I mean?
If you really want to have on
a mind altering,
you know,
experienced,
that's easily doable.
Everyone I think in the whole country has access to,
you know,
mad amounts of Keith and,
and marijuana and has,
she shouldn't and different grades and different places and
they're not a booze culture.
Right.
And like they're a dope culture and that doesn't mean you're not in violent.
I think that's always a funny joke because it's true,
you know that stoners don't commit violence.
But I would think rosters and gangsters just proved the theory that you,
yeah,
you can be high.
He's stoned and still fuck.
The Hawaiians like smoke.
While I was going to say a lot of people's houses,
so they'll get high and be like,
yeah,
maybe they're nicer than they.
They would
have been if it wasn't with the,
we just certainly they're going to stop after it and get something.
They'll,
they won't kill you.
They won't beat you to death.
They'll let you live.
The,
um,
the,
uh,
the Hindus had something called Soma,
which to this day they don't know exactly what it was,
but it was so important to them.
They had all these,
these beautifully written texts on how Great Soma was compared it to all these
other things.
Better than Indra,
better than Brahma,
all these different things.
Soma was the,
the best psychedelic drug and no one knows what the fuck it is really to this.
Yes.
It was so important to them,
but it's written of Britain of but they don't know what it,
what it,
what was in inside of it.
Whether it was a common atory thing,
right.
Like they know that they're,
there was,
people would mix things together.
There was sometimes they would mix certain psychedelics,
they would mix,
you know,
different things.
Like even bad ideas like people of mixed mushrooms and a Iowasca and apparently
that's not a good idea that really fucks you up.
But they uh,
they don't know what the combination was.
They don't know what Soma meant,
but whatever it was,
it was the continental.
It was unbelievably profound.
It was like,
it was one of the most important things that,
that existed in the world.
And we don't know what the fuck are doc is this good question.
I don't know if I could tell you that if under the Duncan Trussell was here,
he snap that shut off and I,
I forgot the name of the plant that the tightness snorted up there now is these,
there's been so many throughout history,
but for us in this day and age,
it's fascinating to me that we're the,
as far as we know,
we're the furthest along without any catastrophe where they've,
we've managed to evolve culture to this crazy point of infinite and information,
just distribution of it instantaneously.
And yet we still at this day and age ridicule that idea.
We ridicule these incredibly potent,
creative,
inspiring experiences,
mind and life changing experiences.
And as a culture,
we be little them.
We,
we,
we make it down to like a joke.
You're high.
Yeah.
And if you talk about it,
you're a silly person and you're not to be taken seriously.
Right.
You know,
I've,
I've had conversations with people where they,
you know,
they said,
well,
what is it really changed the way you look at the life the most?
I'm like psychedelic experiences and they look at you like you just said
something fucking,
you did your burn doing heroin.
Yeah.
You're,
you're,
you're smoking meth and run into the wall.
Like you're an idiot.
Like,
Oh God.
She's just really just say that.
Like,
it's not even something people,
most people are ignorant to what the,
the true experience is really all about and ignorant to how long they've
probably been a part of human history and what they've probably shaped if human
history.
There's no,
that's true.
I Dunno.
I find too that there is a huge resistance toward it.
I talk about it sometimes and I've done them.
Um,
and once you've done them and seen the alternate reality that exists and,
and kind of come in touch with that,
it does change your point of view because you realize that everything is so
fluid and that's levels of consciousness and not just the one horrible one that
we're stuck in all the time.
Now we're frauding each other.
There's,
you know,
varied levels of existence.
It's a real uncomfortable idea for a lot of people,
Joe.
Yeah.
Because it fucks up there.
Well ordered life or their belief system or whatever it is they're going for.
And um,
people prefer faith based staff,
which is weird to me because it's easier to just accept.
Well,
I mean,
it doesn't require a gyration aghast gas as much,
but I hadn't quite considered as much as she had the idea that psychedelic drugs
shapes him.
Many ideas.
But now that you mentioned that,
of course it's true.
You don't need an alien invasion.
Do,
you can get an alien invasion in an hour and 20 minutes.
Okay.
Yeah.
Seven grams going an isolation tank.
You'll have a fucking alien very well.
And it'll happen.
It'll happen in your brain.
Really.
It'll be real.
Yeah.
Like whether or not it's actually physically happening,
who cares what's happening?
That's the subjectivity of it.
It's just a hallucination.
Says who and who cares.
Okay.
Because either way it's happening,
whether,
whether or not you want to say it didn't really,
it wasn't really happening or whether you want to say that you really were
experiencing something that was real,
that you could only see while you're under the influence of the mushroom.
But it's real and around you all the time,
whichever one that is.
Either way you have the experience and the experience is incredibly powerful
and,
and beneficial to you as a human.
I think it is because it opens up your mind.
I think people are terrified to lose their ego.
You know what I mean?
Cause
if you're IGA dissolves,
then you're in a,
in another state where you can't control your emotions and then all the things
that you're repressing and suppressing come rushing back.
And for some people they're tenuously cleaned to reality at all times anyway.
And a push like that threatens them.
And like you say,
it gets lumped in with heroin.
It's not actually,
you know,
like we always argue that marijuana is,
is a mild hallucinogenic and you know,
therefore
a safer and fun or alternative to being drunk,
uh,
unnecessarily or blah,
blah,
blah.
As Louis Armstrong said,
what it's worth,
it's worth a hundred assistants,
uh,
worth a hundred assistance.
Yeah,
he said,
I don't know.
Oh No.
He would have said it's,
it's better than a hundred whiskeys.
Sorry.
He said he always considered it a friend and assistant.
Oh,
that's funny.
Which I thought was really funny,
but it's like,
it's Alex or like if you say,
if you took psychedelics,
uh,
people go,
you know,
you're a drug addict.
Well,
if you smoke weed,
you're a pothead.
You know,
when I am dead,
I am as well.
But what I found out that you were,
uh,
I thought,
when,
uh,
I found out that you were the one who actually did you introduce Doug Benson to
marijuana?
That's the legend.
If you saw that Warner Hertzog movie,
uh,
it's written on one of the cave walls.
There's a,
there's a Petroglyph of Doug and I stylized of course,
you can't hardly recognize it.
You can see my glasses.
It's a from hundreds of years ago.
And Doug and I were in San Diego at the Pacific Beach Improv.
If you remember that one.
No,
I don't.
Well there was this 58,
um,
we had just finished doing a roast at the friars net.
We,
um,
we're playing San Diego in a,
he claims that he had smoked before,
but not on high.
You know what I mean?
Like he'd had some,
so cause a lot of times,
you know,
you'll have to get high a few times before it kicks in.
Uh,
and then I brought a bunch of weed and I remember what I remember is the Condo
was near the beach and we just fucking do forces and you know,
we would just go to the beach every day you get high.
And then when we weren't at the beach,
we would watch MTVs beach party.
Oh my God.
I remember him laying on the couch laughing hysterically at one point and
kicking his legs in the other.
And I was like,
let's go get fish tacos.
And he was like,
dude,
you know,
and like,
it was just that stupid of a weekend.
We,
let's fucking,
and then at night we'd go desats we're working at the umbrella.
Right.
And,
uh,
he claims that was where he started.
And I guess the carefree lifestyle that we were living that week seduced him so
hard because if it's beguiling poetry that he realized he as an independent
soul,
he could finally take control of his own destiny.
But I had a kid say to me once where I was on the road and like Addison,
Texas or something,
and the guy who was working with a nice fellow and he would go out and you'd buy
like peanut that I ran like cereal that you'd see on TV and stuff,
which made me laugh cause I'm from San Francisco,
you know,
and like,
he would come back with like a shopping list you'd see on television,
like wonder bread and,
and he's a nice fellow.
Uh,
and he would,
he would run and whatnot.
And I was late.
I remember what year it was.
It was,
I was watching the Nita Hill hearings on TV and that was a Raiders game that
weekend or a niners game and there was a fire in the East Bay and you could see
the fire boot camp last year was 90 90 91 somewhere in there.
Wow.
Laying on the couch smoking weed and he goes,
you're going to smoke pot all fucking day proofs.
And I go,
let me ask you something.
Whatever his name was,
Danny,
again,
let me ask you something.
Who kills every night you do it?
Ah,
you have your program.
Well people,
it was born,
Gee,
that was trapped in the condo.
There was no,
it was one of those ones that wasn't near anything.
Waffle house or something.
But if you want it to be tactical about like a comics time creating,
it's all day and it's all day watching TV and you're,
you could be scanning for something that inspires you enough to be your next
closing bit.
So you're actually working.
So even when you're lounging,
you're working.
I see.
If I think of stepping in Dad,
I learned that if I wake up in the middle of the night,
I go,
I need to do the thing tomorrow.
I have to think of this.
And then I think of it and you know,
I,
I would argue that the creative process,
you can manufacture it.
Yes.
Um,
but it works better if you don't anyway.
Yeah.
It's a,
everybody goes dry.
Sometimes you gotta drive it.
Also working hard makes you not go dry.
That's true too.
It's a muscle.
Yeah.
I think the,
the,
the is there's like a vibe that you get into when you're really writing a lot
and that vibe sort of like just it,
it,
it becomes like a part of your consciousness and then the,
the more you feed it and the more you do it,
I think that's what the thing with everything,
every,
everything that a person does,
whether it's an art form or a musical instrument,
and if it isn't an art form,
it's not an important job,
but go on.
True.
It is true.
Yeah.
The idea of the creative process is something that's always been so fascinating
to me.
And like I love listening to how other people do it.
And especially comics,
like some of them are just fucking,
they just sit down and put in the time.
They just put in the hours and some of them just sit around and watch things all
day and scratch their head and look at the Internet and just poke around and
pride,
you know?
And then some of 'em they just,
uh,
they just write and,
and stand up for them.
Some people write in blog form,
don't you love when you think a joke springs fully formed from your breast and
you haven't thought of it,
it just comes out and do it and it's perfect.
And you go,
uh,
like people always say,
you know,
whatever,
the Beatles,
um,
how did you write that song?
And sometimes don't call.
Honestly,
I sat down and,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I had it.
I didn't write it.
I,
yeah,
it came out.
And like every once in a while there'll be a joke that you think of and it's
just the right one.
Yeah.
And it made it not be like genius or anything.
It's just that feeling of when it um,
that your,
that your subconscious pushed it out and you weren't fucking with it in any way
and therefore it's perfection.
It's different than something you work worked
on.
Yeah.
There's this weird thing of,
again it goes back to the ego,
this weird thing of what whoever the fuck you think of yourself as,
you know,
this self defining sort of image that you know,
you put up as like sort of a wall for touching.
Yeah.
And when you want to take credit for the idea,
what would,
the way creativity comes,
it comes when you're in the state of like,
like open when you're open to receive it.
When you're really thinking about things like completely all your resources are
on the thing.
Not about the bullshit,
not about like trying to craft an image on stage or trying to formulate
something that you think is going to make the back of the room laugh instead of
that it's,
it's all coming from like a true openness and then they did.
It just comes like as you,
sometimes it's just like moments it,
you know,
these,
these bursts of ideas will come to you and they are just gifts from the
university and they hit you like waves and he can't even write them down quick
enough and you're giggling while you're writing and it's like a gift.
It's like a gift for thinking the right way or a gift for approaching it with
the correct respect.
Like realizing that you are the lucky one to be able to tune into this.
It's not that you have this fabulous person who you know is so awesome because
you say funny shit.
No,
you're the lucky one that has found this ability to tune into these ideas and
you should praise these ideas and honor these ids.
That's true.
I think just pushing yourself to think of something.
I repeat myself a million times,
but to think of something new when you're riffing,
it's how I,
it's really hard,
like on the podcast,
I,
uh,
I'll just attempt things sometimes that aren't that funny,
but I'm like trying to,
you know,
like disconnect so that you're,
you're kind of trying to automatic,
right.
If you can,
do you do your podcast entirely by yourself?
Yeah.
Wow,
that's awesome.
Talk to the crowd and I do it in front of a crowd always.
Wow.
Solo is life.
Whoa.
I want the live.
What do you do with that?
I prefer it's makes me more perform,
you know,
I want to perform more and also,
I'm sorry,
where,
where do you want to thank you for asking.
I'm at the bar live.
It's tonight for goodness sakes.
I did it at the bar,
the other two in La and I do it all of our,
what?
I love that place still in West Hollywood.
Orlewicz Lubitsch Ernst Lubitsch Lubitsch.
Yeah.
Lubitsch bar.
Lubitsch Lea bit.
That sounds so hip and awesome.
It's fun.
And then I get back in front of bar that backs like a nice low stage.
Greg Proops we'll be performing there.
You're doing your fucking podcast,
front of a live on it.
So to me,
I need to like watch this now.
I do that live and uh,
I'm liking this.
This week I'm for London and I'm going to do it in Dublin this week and London,
England,
Wieland's pub and Devlin and the 1910,
the Soho Theater in London on the second.
And then um,
then I come home and I go to Bloomington,
Indiana,
the attic,
which is supposed to be a very nice club and I'm going to do the podcast there.
I tried to do it at every place I go.
Oh.
And a,
I do it live.
I take questions on the air,
never in la very much.
I've done it.
I don't do that much.
But now on the road,
always one part of the show as people get to get up and ask me questions.
The show is called the smartest man in the world.
It's a joke.
I don't think I'm the smartest man unwell.
But you go on the radio and people go like sore you rule or the smartest man,
you're like,
no.
Are you the biggest Douche in the world?
Like who would do that?
It's a joke obviously.
Obviously I have an attitude and I have some kind of comedy.
Yeah.
So I take questions and then I also take email questions and I read them and I
don't read them beforehand.
I just,
Oh,
that's great.
I read them on the air.
So it's,
you know,
people will write me and now,
because you know,
it's,
it's been a couple of years now that it'll be like proof adopolis you know,
dear people of the sun,
you know,
perpendicular,
like trying to think of these lengthy.
So that part's fun.
And then they'll all read it back to the audience and then be like,
and then I'll try to answer it on the air.
So I got one once and I can't remember what it was.
Oh.
And it was a great question.
Uh,
I can't remember who wrote Matt or some short ones,
a little name.
In any case,
it was a beard's period.
Never question mark or beards period.
Never really question mark.
And I went,
that's not a question.
That's a series of extremely short sentences.
Uh,
and then I,
I went in and maybe 25 minutes on this novel that I would write if you were with
me and how we go to Mendocino and get high.
And uh,
the whole going shopping and having a barbecue and drinking later.
And then that's why I wouldn't wear a beard because I would be scruffy at the
end of the four day and I'd be trying to write my novel and you'd be refuting my
novel as I read it to you first.
I wouldn't read it to you.
I'd be too precious.
And then upon demand on,
and this all came out of nowhere.
I have no intention of doing any of this.
And,
and to me that's the jumping off point.
Right?
And it was the shortest,
stupidest thing.
And it was only because I'd said I didn't like beards on the show.
And like I said,
I don't like hats,
you know,
or what is it?
There's a few things I don't think men should wear.
Look what hats and beards and hats.
Um,
I don't,
I don't look at it and how people who look good in it.
I say wear a hat.
So,
but what if men want to wear a hat?
Because I just don't feel like combing their hair.
They just,
that's what I came as guys who wear baseball.
I'm not judgmental about right,
right.
Just where it just throw it all out right now.
He said that you,
you're attacking you also,
you're also at your show.
Like if you were going to go out with a girl,
would you wear your baseball ass?
Why would dress exactly.
That was exactly,
I do it cause I,
I don't know if you want them to like you.
I like to highlight,
come,
listen.
Hi very easily.
I don't like to look at people.
If somebody is bothering me,
I don't want to deal with to cut them out.
I get that now those extraordinarily well.
Well,
okay it,
see my game is wrong.
It's just his game is being him.
It's like your,
your game is you,
but your game is funny.
When you shit on other people who aren't doing your game.
Slogans of the show is I'm bound to shit on something you love.
Yeah.
And what's wrong with that?
Why does everybody have such a hard time with that?
Everyone's so goddamn sensitive.
It's so silly if you can't laugh at someone making fun of you,
that you're,
you're being a silly person.
I agree.
So that's how we get it and it's great fun.
And I get that sometimes people ask questions.
Uh,
I have no idea what they're going to say and it sounds amazing.
I've got a couple of running jokes that evolved,
evolved out of,
uh,
out of nowhere,
you know,
like just shit that I like to talk about.
And one of them is for some reason the Negro Leagues,
right?
I'm a fan of baseball and I,
I started talking about Satchel Paige and Negro leaders in night.
I play in Scotland a year ago and uh,
well they don't know what the Negro Leagues are,
you know,
and a guy at the end of the show,
we're doing questions and he goes,
what about Satchel Paige?
And you're like,
you know,
you cry.
A little wheelchair goes down my cynical face.
You've made a connection.
Podcasting is the coolest thing that comics have been able to do in the,
in my entire career,
Nolan in TV cooler then.
I mean,
I love the stage,
you know,
you can't pull me on fucking stage right.
And the ham bone.
But I mean,
podcasting by,
by a long mile is the most creative outlet I've had the most challenging.
Uh,
doing it by myself with the crowd has been something I think I needed to do
forever and I don't,
didn't know that I needed to do that.
That sounds amazing.
Doing it the way you're doing.
It sounds really fun because it's like people have a chance to see different
ideas explored every week and doing it live in front of an audience like that.
Getting to see riff and just completely go off the cuff.
And knowing that it's absolutely completely off the cuff.
That's so fun.
I mean,
I read pounds and newspaper articles and Hawaiian about it.
Shit,
you know,
it's one of the boring part.
Uh,
and then there's the questions and,
you know,
yeah,
the,
the podcasting thing is done.
The only thing that's like,
in my opinion,
is truly complimentary to the standup because it really gets you to see the way
it guy's brain works.
Like one of the things I love about guys coming on that I haven't talked to
before,
like you,
like maybe we might have said like 10 words to each other ever that it comes
like,
hi,
what's up man?
What's going on?
Everything cool.
You know?
Um,
is that,
uh,
when you get to compare and,
and,
and like see the different,
it's very inspiring to listen to other people's creative process.
Oh,
well that's,
it is,
I think it's,
I have been on so many different,
uh,
comics podcast and that's the other fun as part of podcasting is it's giving the
audience something that they never had before when we were young and we would
listen to comedy albums or even guys get interviewed occasionally on TV or the
radio and exchange of ideas between comics.
You don't fucking hear it.
You never fucking heard it.
It was never a craft and people now people podcastings radio.
Yeah,
it is.
It's an audio format or whatever.
Largely,
but except for all right.
Um,
I was looking at the camera.
Who's here?
Yeah.
How's it going?
Hello.
Sophisticated motherfucking,
I'll look at you and hug you.
Hey,
could you imagine if we had audio of like Kennison having a conversation with a
hex?
Right.
We didn't get that.
We the,
this is the dressing room,
uh,
for,
the world finally.
Uh,
and that there's a lot of funny people who can express themselves in this format
and that,
because it's like a,
you know,
whatever the,
there's a neph rules that make it work because it's Mike's and it's audio and it
has to be a certain length.
It can't be seven hours,
you know,
unless you're making a right,
the bender,
the thing is though,
little Sapelo listened to him at work a lot.
I can give them really long ones.
We do like three hours all the time.
Oh,
I,
I've been,
I do an hour and a half at two and the two ones that I think are a little long,
cause it's just me,
like I say so often,
you know,
come on after an hour,
really?
One day,
dude.
You're like,
yeah,
but people say to me,
Oh,
I love the long ones because I drive three hours to work,
or I'm on the train for two hours.
Why did you do a fucking one hour and 10 minute one?
I needed a one hour and 48 and in it.
And I think the other thing that's really cool is that they're free.
Like that's a Oh really cool thing of repeating tag role.
Like it's,
that's the connection that we get to deal with.
This TV is wonderful and a one day I'll be on it again.
But the,
I think that,
uh,
the connection that we get with this is just a different thing altogether.
Yeah.
I completely agree.
It's a tell immediate and you get to see what the dude is really like,
you know,
I need,
well I'm sure you do cheat you do you work lab all the time.
But I meet at my podcast way different than I would approach standup standup.
Shall I go,
I'm backstage,
I look at my notes,
I've,
you know,
drink,
whatever,
go on and do it.
Uh,
and then go back or maybe say hi to a few people at the podcast.
I go out in the audience before the show and talk to everybody.
Wow.
And then sometimes after the show too,
so it's more of like a town hall meeting show starts.
It's not,
Greg Proops is coming into the building and I fucking have met you.
And we'd like you go to England and English people sometimes they're a little
reticent,
you know,
that they're not ready for you to come up and go hi.
And I'll say,
this is your punishment.
You have to meet me before I go up there.
And then they,
you know,
and then,
but afterwards they're like,
that was really different that he came up and talked to us and I don't spend a
year with everybody.
I go,
hi,
thanks for coming.
You know,
I'll were you,
but I touch everybody and it's made a huge difference to me as an a performer to
like that connection is something.
And I never had with the crowd before.
I was never the touchy high five.
Anybody,
dude.
No,
I mean I'm lovable.
Obviously.
I'm,
I'm almost irresistibly engaging Joe.
I think you found that have been the last two and a half hours.
But uh,
and your audience of course,
I think fell in love right away.
Yeah,
they fell them up right away.
Um,
they,
that's a great idea though.
It's contrary to the standard thing that they would always show up to preach us,
which was,
you know,
magic.
Keep them.
You don't want to see,
don't let them see.
You see,
you hear the wizard of Oz.
Yeah.
Like I started a introducing my friends at the shows.
Like we would do a scenario.
You are first and then I would,
yeah,
and I would get on the microphone.
There we go.
Don't you tell you think it's better if they hear your voice for the first time
when you were on stage.
I want you stop the crazy thinking that,
that all that income to see you.
Yeah.
They'll be disappointed.
I'm glad to hear you're there.
All that and that you support the other people in the act.
It makes sense.
Yeah.
It makes that connection.
It does.
Instead of,
you know,
he plays clubs in colleges and they,
you come out,
I said,
see,
you know,
I can scarf and a grain elevator,
you know?
I mean,
I love Glamor.
I really do.
And I like to dress up a lot and everything that,
like you say that,
that old paradigm of Shit is this where it's,
you know,
uh,
they were saving you as this special treat coma,
block the ticket to see you,
man.
I know you're playing,
I saw you outside smoking a joint,
you know,
like it's not that mystifying like we're not,
I mean any standup it works because you have to have,
Ooh,
I thought it standard but works cause uh,
that's cool.
I think he's got a remote control.
No,
no,
he just touch them.
Some of them were on remote control or something.
Just did own thing.
Anyway,
I do that and I never would have done it before.
And like,
uh,
I played the Bell House in Brooklyn and I'm there again in January on the 19th.
If you're listening and um,
there's about 350 people and this is nice.
Wow.
You know,
I've done this a hundred fucking years and I can't draw big crowds anywhere in
the world.
You know,
like I play around the world,
but I don't get a thousand people ever.
And,
you know,
unless I'm with,
someone huge,
but to get that many people to come to the podcast and that's all it was.
And I did an hour and they're 45,
whatever,
you know,
as long enough to fucking charge people 20 months or whatever.
And uh,
I met everyone before and then afterward I talked to almost like everybody
didn't want her to talk and I stayed for hours like Babe Ruth and just fucking,
you know,
hey,
and people give you pictures and they talked to you and you just talk about him
and shit.
And I thought I would have never cared this much before.
What now?
Like his,
I'm middle aged,
you know,
and I love comedy,
which he knows what they mean.
Oh,
absolutely.
Want to be a comedian.
And not that I didn't ever want to bet,
but I don't know Joe,
my,
you know,
I did the first one,
the,
uh,
Mountain Ryan who produced Judge Benson's show,
and Jimmy Pardot show,
uh,
came to me and said,
you want to do show?
And I was like,
well,
what do I do?
And they go wall,
you know.
And I said,
well no one will listen.
They'll go,
people listen to me.
And uh,
and then I,
we just had not to do interviews.
I'll do it on my own.
Cause I dentist audible show previously,
like in the old days when we were overfunded on the web,
I did audible.com yeah,
yeah.
They had a bunch and I've got to do one and they paid me good money in the whole
thing and nobody listened cause no one had phones then it was 2000 till 2005
they were really innovators.
So they didn't,
nobody had a,
no one even had mp3s.
I mean like the Ed iPods video you'd have to down,
you know,
my,
Steve Marmel had some sort of a deal with them where he did a two minutes of new
content and I meet you.
I did it every like me,
Steve,
I know they wanted you to do a cheer at the time.
I've never been crazy though,
how much new standup.
So I took that for fucking five years.
So I thought,
well I'll just do that.
But like in an expanded,
but let's make it fun and have drinks and so the audience can have a drink and
we all login.
How do you handle photographs before the show?
At the podcast?
Nobody really wants to do them before they kind of want to do in there,
I'm sure.
Really?
Yeah.
Usually I think it feels like as soon as I don't like it at a standup shows
much.
I mean after I'll do that afterwards,
after I,
let me,
I know wine for a fucking minute.
William,
I always say hi to.
I have like a big line of people after they left.
Did you have a tank?
I don't hear anybody else that that does it.
I love hearing that you do that.
Well,
I do it at the podcast for sure.
I've standup show I'm,
you may not be so lucky that I do it at almost every standup show unless there's
something going on.
You know,
you're like a gentleman and philosopher,
you know,
you,
you your,
your job now is so important for what you've been doing and it's the culmination
of all,
you know,
the TV and all that.
This is the reward.
You know,
like you're saying you're rewarded by a gas.
Yeah.
You want to talk to everybody,
your show man,
they want to cap to you.
That's how important you are to them.
Yeah,
I know.
I don't think if this is a reward I think of this is just a,
I just found like a real cool spot to expand.
All right then it's the culmination
of all your thoughts.
We'll just fortunate that something came along that would lend itself to someone
who has so many different weird ideas in their head.
Yeah.
You can't ever do in the form of like a radio show.
You haven't caught up to us yet.
We're still running wild were stolen and wild man.
This is still gangster pirate stuff and everybody thinks it's all,
you know,
the 30 somethings who who cover us,
uh,
are already hip to the jive but they don't realize that the whole world doesn't
know about podcasting at all.
World doesn't need a huge coming up.
They're blowing up and you know what else is happening.
Podcasts are feeding other podcasts are finding about like,
we have had so many guys come from this podcast and then start their own and
then we help push their pockets.
To me it's an insane reached people.
Your circle is
uh,
you know,
well they always say,
ah,
uh,
every scene needs a club house and this is the clubhouse,
right?
This is the scene.
Yeah,
the,
the ice houses.
Uh,
it's such an awesome place to,
because it's been around since like 1961 or something like,
oh,
I played here in 54.
They have this faith healing.
If you go into the ice house,
like you step into that showroom,
that's a feeling like that place has been performed in for decades.
You feel it.
I mean,
it sounds crazy.
I know it sounds crazy,
but there's a happiness in that room,
man.
That's a and Bible building.
We have a show there tonight.
Joe Diaz is going to be there.
Sam Tripoli,
Adam Hunter,
the guy who got me in trouble for saying his joke on an FX UFC fight.
Um,
Greg Fitzsimmons that I mentioned him already.
Who else?
So you're having trouble with some other people.
It got some solid fucking performers.
Oh,
Thompson Jura is going to be here to least gentlemen.
You don't want to miss that.
So it's not tonight.
Tonight at 10 o'clock.
So am I here for three hours then?
No,
buddy.
We're just,
we're just chilling.
We're,
we're,
we got to wrap up soon because Brian has to head down to San Diego where he is
going tonight.
I gotta go work tonight to Brian is a with Doug Benson,
your buddy tonight at the
American comedy Co.
It's at eight o'clock.
Tickets still available@americancomedycode.com.
Surely not.
And if you've never been there,
it's an amazing little club.
It's,
I have not been there.
What's it like straight here?
It goes up.
Beautiful place.
Drive San Diego.
What's it?
Love it.
I love it.
The American comedy company,
he's a real low ceiling.
Tight seating.
Go down squares a very solid,
I really wished them all the best.
And apparently there's another place called madhouse comedy.
Yeah,
down the street.
I was in old town.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know.
It's an area where people walk
for American comedy goes that gas lamp.
And uh,
I remember where the other place,
okay.
It's the shit.
It's San Diego is awesome.
It's really a bad ass suit ages.
It's just,
it's funny,
20 years ago or when are,
you know,
50 years ago when I first started,
uh,
that,
that was a road Gig we always did.
There was a million gigs in San Diego.
Always played in La Jolla and fucking,
they started out in San Francisco,
right?
Yeah.
And our road gigs are all bay area and northern,
you know,
in Oregon,
Reno,
that kind of,
I started my show business career in San Francisco as well,
where a fisherman's wharf.
I was eight years old.
I had a magic show.
Really?
Yeah.
That was my,
that's how I started.
I did,
I said I had a magic show.
I would let,
somebody gave me a magic show,
like a thing,
a little top hat and shit.
So I'd go out and get,
get donations.
It's ridiculous.
Why were you living in San Francisco?
Yeah,
I lived in San Francisco when I was a kid from age seven to 11.
Oh,
that's cool.
Fascinating Times.
It was right when the Vietnam War was ending and a really interesting living in
San Francisco like that young of my life during that era and the seventies
really shaped my,
uh,
I was going to say it to you at all.
It did a lot.
There was a lot of,
especially my attitude towards gay people,
I've never understood.
I grew up with gay people.
So like to me it was always normal.
And by the way,
it was always something that you can make fun of.
As long as you're not being a dick about it.
You can make fun of everything.
And this,
the idea of a homophobia,
I didn't even know it existed until I was about 13 or 12.
12.
I was in Florida hanging around with my keys.
The Dawn,
my parents moved to Florida.
We moved from San Francisco to Florida.
And um,
there's a Cuban friend of mine,
his dad fuck it,
through the newspaper on the table.
I can't fucking believe this shit.
He was so mad.
And he goes,
they're going to let these faggots marry each other.
And I remember I was,
I was like 12 years old.
I was like,
what the fuck do you care?
Like what,
what are you nuts?
You're going,
you're why you care.
Like gay guys want a marriage.
It like,
what did,
it was weird.
I was like,
this poor guy's like,
he's broken or something.
It's like,
this is my friend's dad.
Like what an idiot.
And that I remember thinking,
it took me a while to realize it,
but I was like,
wow,
people are way stupider in Florida than they are in San Francisco.
It was like going from a completely different world.
San Francisco is in a very unusual place.
It poison to you because I've never dropped the attitude from there.
I have never,
they all the,
all the information I believe in is from there.
High down.
Uh,
it was a,
it's a huge rude awakening when you get into the world and realize that it ain't
that way and ain't that fucking way.
It's amazing how places like San Francisco evolve.
Like you have these weird pockets of like really smart people and really cool
people and it's,
it's like that whole area,
the,
the tech area with,
you know,
uh,
like we're the,
all those rich dudes live and like Palo Alto and Atherton and stuff like that,
that,
that area is filled with intelligent people.
It's really amazing.
It's a to hotbed of interesting,
intelligent people.
It's weird.
And therefore the demands are different.
You're going to go to a place and they're going to have artisinal bread,
salincha cheese and awesome wine.
I realize it's also an economic thing,
but it's,
it's a cultural thing too.
Uh,
um,
uh,
the sensitivity,
like you say,
I didn't,
I didn't realize how red necky the world was.
And I used to say it years ago on stage when I played in England and stuff.
I'm always looking for a place that's not rednecky,
but I never find it.
I don't know if that's still true,
but you know,
you're just going to run into it.
It's just going to happen.
This going to be a Yang.
Well,
yeah,
there's always going to be Kimberly.
They're going to let faggots and Mary,
what it was Chris clue that wasn't the punter just said,
there's not going to make you a raging cock monsters.
Why are we said the people that are worried about gay marriage or either really
dumb or secretly worried the dicks are delicious and there's,
there's no,
there's no other options.
No.
It's like,
why?
Why else would you care?
Selling is about filling one.
But you know what?
I think that recently,
I don't want to ascribe too much to the last election,
but the last did,
uh,
was definitely a forum on that as well as about a million other issues.
But that was an issue that did get knowledge to gay,
a senator and Wisconsin and uh,
there's a bisexual congressperson,
which is hilarious.
Wow.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
And
there's also a Buddhist from Hawaii.
Really interesting.
And uh,
I think that really speaks to what's happening now.
Incremental.
But it happened.
I feel like the gay marriage thing has always been like sort of a beach ball
that gets tossed in the air to distract people,
which is why it never gets resolved.
No.
And Bush didn't want to resolve.
Remember 2004 was about the Sankey marriage and then he didn't do shit.
Like he didn't do shit about abortion or anything else.
He actually didn't really do anything about any social issues and make people
wildly angry.
Was he the first guy that would let you really clearly see that the presidency
is not real and then like all those decisions are being made by other people?
Well,
I wasn't old enough to be with it.
I mean,
I was a teenager or a young,
beautiful teenage boy with legs,
like a slender impala as I slid through life and my Adidas.
Um,
and I like the wind in the background.
Yeah.
Duh,
Duh.
Yeah.
And I've got a long way to go.
Cool.
Thank you.
Very good to the,
I'll do Michael McDonald all day long.
And,
uh,
yeah,
I went,
I went through Watergate when I was like early teenager and I remember it and I
remember the cynicism even 12 or 13,
14 year old like,
okay,
the president can be brought down,
the press has this power.
Uh,
the respect that,
that God in this country,
uh,
the ending of the war and then watching the late seventies where we thought we
were going to have,
uh,
the equal rights amendment,
we thought black people were going to be equal.
We thought Indians were going to get a piece of the pie.
And then Reagan came along and all that kind of 60,
Steph got washed in the,
you took mushrooms,
bath and everybody,
the,
the media and the corporate entities and whatever.
That was I,
that was,
I think when I first,
I was probably 19 or 20 when Reagan got elected.
Like to me,
he was the first one.
I thought,
you're,
you know,
you're not up to the job.
The mentally,
you know,
that we're going to have you do it and you're just going to be this sort of
beautiful mountain of,
you know,
reassuring hooding for creepy moment because it was morning in America.
Do you remember that?
One morning in America,
that's what he called his presidency because Carter had such a bad recession and
couldn't get anything done and the Democratic Congress to fight and then it kind
of all went to shit by the end of the term.
Right.
And the passages,
the hostages,
they cat.
And who knows what fucking happened,
right?
Whether Reagan got them released out,
ball of light.
In any case,
having said all that,
he called like his first term mourning in America.
Like we'd been in the darkness,
you know,
after it was clear that 12 years of Republican,
14 Years Republican presidency in Vietnam was the root of
yeah,
what had turned everything horrible.
The corrupt CIA and the drug dealing and a chicanery such an obvious narrative.
Well,
and then like,
so Bush for eight years of snatching,
grabbing,
making illegal war and fucking horrible,
um,
fundamentalism and narrowness in the national dialogue.
And then,
you know,
the last four years people kind of okay.
And then the last election was like,
Eh,
it's clear again
that the big paradigm is shifting in the right direction.
Well,
something's going to have to happen.
I think socially it's certainly in the right direction.
Or what old publicans are going to have to embrace gay marriage in medical
marijuana.
Those things are going to happen.
Yeah.
Well it should.
Abortion should be legal marijuana cause you know what?
It benefits everybody.
You don't think it does because you don't know how to use it.
It's really that simple.
It's like saying that fucking saws shouldn't be legal because some people are
going to cut their feet off.
Well,
you know?
Yeah.
And it doesn't necessarily mean a crime wave that's going to be less crime.
That's what you were saying.
You were going to be nicer.
Yeah.
What people don't understand is it marijuana unquestionably increases
sensitivity.
It changes the way you feel about things.
It makes you,
it makes you more sense.
It makes food taste better.
It just changes the whole dynamic of life.
And when something like that gets introduced in your system,
it gives you a new sense of understanding and that can help you and push you to
evolve your personality.
That's it can be a good thing.
And even like when people talk about paranoia,
like they take it in to get paranoid.
It's not a bad thing to be paranoid every now and then.
Just get an accurate assessment,
how fucking vulnerable you really are and how lucky you really are.
And maybe just turn that around and use it to,
to,
to be thankful and you know,
to push out positive energy because of that fucking paranoid.
Don't be scared of weed is what I'm trying to say.
They need it.
Uh,
Cesar doubt fear the reefer.
He doesn't know the wound.
I don't think that's what they say,
isn't it?
I don't know.
Maybe are seen as now it would've been a better song.
There's not that many really powerful songs about weed except rap songs.
Like you have to go to Cypress Hill if you really want to get a powerful song
about,
here's the thoughts.
[inaudible] uh,
uh,
Jim about array for five feet long.
A little bit hot,
but not too strong.
You'll be high,
but not for long if you're a viper,
what is that?
Fats Waller.
Who is he?
That's all I was a songwriter era and from Harlem,
uh,
in the twenties and thirties.
I guess he died but one more choose pretty young.
And he wrote a honeysuckle rose and he wrote,
I hate you because your feet are too big.
And um,
he had a bunch of weed songs now.
Dude.
You know so much about so much weird shit.
Well,
I was going to say you do.
I mean I've never heard about Jane and [inaudible] and uh,
uh,
you're insane.
Uh,
a historian who dissected the Dead Sea Scrolls,
who's an Ingersoll as John Marco Allegro Allegro.
Why can't I think of a late round?
These are just repeated subjects to death to me.
It's so funny when I can explain it to somebody who's never heard them before
because I'm such a Dork.
That's all I think about is this shit I think about.
It is funny how you can get on these like crazy paths of knowledge and store
weird shit that comes out and people were looking at like,
what the fuck do you know that format?
Right?
People say,
why do you need other things?
Which I always think is funny cause the answer is easy cause I,
I'm learning.
Yeah.
Well for some people you can get stuck in a bad situation where you,
you showing up and you work with a bunch of dummies,
but it's a good job.
And so you're,
you're on that vibe.
Like every day this talking to dumb,
uninterested people,
bored people,
the,
you know,
and then you go home.
What do you do?
You Watch TV?
Like it's something,
it's hard to find a good conversation.
Sometimes
it is a,
and that's the thing about,
uh,
the podcasts that makes it so interesting.
I mean a lot of Weirdos and people who come to my show or sometimes it's a
specific thing they want to talk about it.
Sometimes it's more general,
but you,
there's no lack of,
uh,
points of view and uh,
you know,
fields of interest.
People are throwing things at me all the time that I should talk about that I
don't know anything about,
you know,
what,
and then get string theory and David Foster Wallace and you know,
this is not,
and I'm like,
I don't fucking know anything about that and if we can just motor it in the
world.
So I tried to learn some things sometimes,
but I don't also don't want to be the person with a little bit of knowledge
about something and he gets everything wrong cause that's more annoying than,
uh,
than my usual pedantic.
I know everything about everything.
Right.
Yeah.
If you,
uh,
if you pretend you know more than,
you know,
shut wrong,
you're shot down immediately to by a million people right now.
Good.
You can't do it.
You should just Google it.
You should Google it.
Well,
no one can Google anything.
That's what I find so funny about the inner webs.
Everybody has a phone on them all the time and yet no one will look up.
No one will click past the first link.
Yeah.
Well,
especially if you're asserting something silly.
Yeah.
This is,
um,
I dunno,
it's a real exciting time.
I think this,
uh,
the,
the ability to,
to have things like your podcast now where you could just,
it just gets released out into the world and then just picks up,
you know,
new viewers and he'd do something like this and I'm sure this is going to have a
bunch of people a download it now from iTunes and get hooked on it.
You know,
it's a,
it's such a beautiful and neat path,
you know,
it's all so clean.
It's like direct to the artist.
Greg Proops takes it.
Greg Proops puts it online.
You download it,
you're connected or like,
oh,
like,
like with one step two is for you putting it up there.
Yeah.
And you can listen to it at your discretion.
You can fast forward it,
you can burn it,
you can copy it and send it to someone else.
I'm sure people deal with you every once in a while.
This guy from like Sweden or something.
And I don't know how he found the,
he's on Facebook.
He'll do a Knicks would,
there's like music behind a part of it and you go the stops really cool.
I wouldn't have thought of that,
you know?
Yeah.
Videos of rants have gone on live.
These like really become these really inspirational where someone spliced in
music and the Eisenhower speeches and it's fucking crazy shit man.
And it's all just people that connect to something on the,
on the Internet.
So we live in strange times.
That's amazing.
Isn't an exciting part.
Is like I'm ready for a lot of the old stuff to go away.
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
I mean I have tradition,
obviously I write with a piece of paper and a pen.
Do you really?
Yeah,
I feel like I can't write as fast that way.
So the ideas slip away from me,
but I do,
um,
write it down before I go on stage because when a,
especially new stuff,
I feel like if I don't physically write it down with a pen and a paper,
I don't remember it the same way.
I,
that's exactly what I was going to say,
Joe.
I've done a survey of every comic I've talked to him the last two or three
years.
Every club I played,
I make everybody get their book out and show me how I go.
Where do you keep your ideas and everybody?
Yeah.
Book a little book with your lists on it.
Yup.
Minor on hotel rooms,
stationary.
Thousands of them,
thousands of pieces of paper.
And I say,
why do you do it that way?
Do you ever ride it on your phone?
Yeah.
Uh,
if I think of a one line and I ride it,
you know,
did it today.
But do you write your whole to the phone?
No.
In the end I have to put it on a piece of paper and read and I just think it's a
mental,
that's the really old fashioned part of performing.
I have a note,
lists of set lists on my phone,
but I'll go to like right before I go on stage sometimes if I want to make sure
that I remember some new shit that I'm working on.
But when I write,
I go,
when are you going to that?
Like trance,
I can do that so much better when I'm typing because I can,
the words just appear like I can type a word in a,
in a second.
Whereas it takes the Kenyan remember if you type no,
but,
but I can write better.
So I,
I get the trance out and I can get more information out as I'm writing.
But then I go back and I'm like,
I fucking write that.
I remember writing that.
Like I'll,
I'll laugh at some of my own shit and then I'll go,
okay,
I got it.
That I've got to keep that part.
Cause I don't even remember writing cause I'd have five hours of writing.
How much do you actually remember?
But the,
the act of actually scribing it into a paper,
a piece of paper.
There's something about that that's like,
it just really like residents.
It just stores in your memory that's like,
it's like a,
we humans have been doing it that way for so long.
It's like
math where it's been five,
seven,
10,000 years since people started writing.
Yeah,
I think there's a real profound connection with the paper.
Yeah.
Have you ever thought about releasing those?
Like with your,
um,
like with a special,
like when you release a special release your notes as well.
Wow.
Now I haven't,
one time I did a fun article for Filter magazine.
The guy came over to me and he said,
how do you,
he saw me fumbling with my notes and I said,
it's all different pieces of hotel stationary.
So I asked my wife to pick it.
He goes,
well that will be the article.
Just I want a picture of these,
you know,
notes as atlas.
And uh,
I said to my wife,
you pick it out.
I give her the folder full of shit.
And she picked out four random ones.
It was one from like Paris,
one from Minnesota,
one from a place I didn't remember being,
it was like and somewhere,
you know,
and then there was another one and then it just sad like Clinton,
you know what on the like,
you know,
corn,
whatever the fuck was on the list to Olsen twins.
And I kind of went through the list as the article and just went like,
yeah,
I was doing Clinton jokes in Paris,
you know,
I,
well I think I slept.
Really,
it's always 92 when I rock the Mike Rock dumb luck or whatever,
you know,
like,
uh,
that there is a weird insight into kind of like what's going on exactly.
Then with all your setlist cause the different notes you make on them and stuff.
I don't know that there's not much to be garnered from,
I mean,
I could probably remember some of the bits and some I couldn't.
So just something that might be cool,
like if I was a fan and I like how it yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
And just see my old self,
I put it up on line or something.
If you just put the photos online,
do you ever see that a website called letters of note?
No.
Uh,
and there's another one,
something of note.
Um,
but letters of notice letters people wrote to each other or even,
oh,
I think there's one called lists of note.
And,
um,
the list of note is just different lists that famous people wrote or anybody you
know,
notable,
like the one I remember is felonious monk,
cause I read it on my show.
A blind is monk,
you know,
uh,
he had different mental problems and stuff.
You know,
if you've ever seen him play like he played and then he said,
get up and walk around the stage,
you know?
Yeah.
And he's extraordinary.
And then he was given drugs and they didn't quite work out,
but anyways,
a genius and he,
he could both compose and arrange and extemporize and his band was,
you know,
kind of
putting the position of having to deal with his,
his personality,
right?
Like,
cause he wasn't like a regular guy who,
hey,
let's,
you know,
I'll be there at five,
he had to kind of be pushed around to places,
but then when he could play,
he was so he wrote a note and on the net it's just how do we address tonight?
Sharp as possible.
Underlined.
Right.
And then,
uh,
if you're,
the drummer I think is something,
you know,
like there's all this like really broken down like the thoughts you have before
you go on stage,
like about the band and how he wanted the band to play and look.
And I would,
I would read that out sometimes.
And so I would say on the show,
how do we adjust tonight at sharp is possible.
Yeah.
Right.
So there's lists of note and there's letters of note.
And then at the last letter of note,
someone sent it to me.
Uh,
was um,
Jackie Robinson went to a luncheon or a dinner at Ike was speaking at,
right.
And Jackie was an executive.
Yeah.
Jackie Robinson was an executive at chock full of nuts.
Coffee,
right?
Like he got a job in the corporate world because he was an intelligent,
capable,
and famous person.
He became an executive,
a chocolate nuts in New York.
And so he went to this like banquet and Eisenhower Spec and it was a lot of
black people there who were in business and Eisenhower said,
you've got to be patient,
right?
You'll chime will come.
And all that.
This is the city's wow.
So Jackie wrote him a very respectful letter but also very pointed,
um,
about your patients.
You know,
and I'm not doing it any justice.
It was,
as you know,
Jim,
Mr President,
having recently attended the lunch out,
I have to say that on behalf of myself and my race,
the time for patients is long passed.
You'll find that over the past several hundred years we've endured nothing but
countless indignant,
you know?
Right,
right,
right.
And then the repast is the next letter Eisenhower wrote him back.
Jim,
Mr. Robinson,
thank you for your letter.
I,
as I take on board what you said and I profoundly,
you know,
Blah Blah Blah and like,
oh wow,
this exchange in a very civil and high faluting language,
not the language that we use now,
but like formal letter writing language,
uh,
with the idea of very explicitly expressed that he no longer had the patients to
eight,
that he felt that why shitty way and why should you have to go to a dinner with
the president,
told him the way we need in the first fucking black guy in the big leagues and
they get a job and fucking business and you know,
trying to run his life and shit.
Right.
And Eisenhower like it.
Well,
you know,
one day schools will be integrated and you want to have to drink it another
faucet and you know,
you don't want to hear that.
And so those kinds of letters I think to me are like fascinating.
So letters of known enlisted node are quite good.
If you want to just,
you mean you don't have to read everything on it that it's,
it's different letters to people and that's fucking Badass.
Yeah,
I will check that nobody writes letters anymore.
In,
in future it will be your setlist of note and your emails of note and your blog
of note the probably be a letter.
Yeah,
it's going away.
The physical act of writing is going away.
If I didn't have to write my set lists down or occasional like fill out a form,
like when I go to Canada or something like that,
I would,
I don't really write anything.
I do.
I mean I ride,
I ride on my computer,
but I write in a book too because it's funner.
Greg Proops you're a bad mother fucker.
Ah,
you're a bad mother fucker for coming on the podcast.
Lightening.
It was fun.
I wish we had more time but we don't have to get as to you.
Um,
so let's do this again man.
Yes,
please.
Oh,
awesome.
Thank you very much ladies and gentlemen.
That's the end of the show tonight.
Ice House Comedy Club in Pasadena.
Joe Dia's,
Sam Tripoli,
Greg Fitzsimmons,
Tom Segura,
Adam Hunter and me.
You dirty bitches.
Can I go up before eight o'clock going out right now
tonight,
eight o'clock the bar or the Chunk Santa Monica Boulevard.
You'll find it.
Boom.
Find that.
And it's tonight in San Diego,
California at American Comedy Co.
It is Doug motherfucking Benson and Brian motherfucking red band.
And that is a what time show?
Eight o'clock be there bitches and no undercover cops.
That shit's greasy.
Okay,
we'll see you fuckers the next week.
Next week we've got Shane Smith.
We got a Monday,
Duncan Trussell,
Chris,
and in the new studio and Wednesday,
Ari Moba Vogrin should fear Holla Shalom.